[Music]
coming up on 5 15 on your Friday morning
we've got a sweet story about the
makeover of this long-standing CCSD logo
into this now it's all rolled up and
kind of a how do they do that about one
of the best or worst Kept Secrets of the
school district's Food Service
Department
hi I'm Marissa Ross the principal of
Aggie Roberts Elementary Marissa rosavug
says it's icing on the cake I mean
cinnamon roll almost 250 pounds of
ingredients in one batch you might say
dough a student not so spontaneously
asks I wonder where the cinnamon roll
came from and I feel the need to explain
no matter how they lay it out no matter
how they cut it the rolls are a smashing
success and to make more than 4 million
of these bad boys every year massive
School District oven racks rise to the
occasion how do they get the icing on
they just roll with it if you think it's
in the bag at that point you better keep
on trucking not only all of the valley
but all over the county hey principal
rossavong let's bring this delicious
story to a heartwarming conclusion the
effort coordination and hours spent on
something as small as a cinnamon roll
show The District's impact on this
community and our children this kind of
teamwork this kind of effort is not only
our mission but our privilege we are
here to serve the students of Clark
County because
we are CCSD
all right whatever you might think about
the new CCSD logo those cinnamon rolls
really aren't the bomb we always want to
know what's cool at school you got
something let us know cool at school
under the Community tab of our website
or email cool at school at 8newsnow.com
uh Sherry I heard you talking about how
the roles look pretty good have you ever
had one uh I don't think I've had one
from CCSD oh my goodness
make an excuse well re-enroll make an
excuse to go visit any school in the
district and stop in the cafeteria they
are unbelievable I like how the video
they went yep they smashed it
and they have this giant icing machine
and the food service department that
factory up there is a story in and of
itself it is like a ginormous kitchen
serving 300 000 students three meals a
day every day of the year we're always
so proud of the casino restaurants yeah
the massive kitchens and stuff they've
got going on but really the school
district and you like you said they feed
a lot of kids